[Música]
alguna vez
ha pensado cómo sería su vida en un país
desconocido sin amigos y sin saber casi
nada de español yo fui una de las
personas que tuvo que dejar todas las
que tenía para empezar a crear una nueva
bien
nací en una zona suburbana en el norte
inglaterra con todos mis amigos hablando
inglés y para muchos años de mi vida yo
no sabía que era el español pero en el
2012 mis papás y yo tuvieron que ir a
vivir en españa y eso cambió mi vida más
que nunca
pero con eso no aprendí casi nada
español todo mis clases eran en inglés y
los que están en español era demasiado
complicadas y como muy paquetes no sé
cuántos de ustedes están de acuerdo de
que el español es importante en las
funciones globales
bueno como algunos de ustedes saben el
español es el segundo idioma más hablado
en el mundo
y es vital para las funciones globales
podemos ver en números 20 por ciento de
la población del mundo habla español y
eso no es contando las personas que
hablan por el segunda lengua
puede ayudarle a conseguir un trabajo
comunicarse con otros y probablemente
saber sean la razón porque así todos mis
amigos vinieron la escuela pero por
ellos para aprender inglés
en su cambio completamente cuando me
vine a la costa rica
tons no había casi nadie que sabía
hablar inglés y un cantidad aún menor
sabía hablarlo correctamente
eso es un shock para muchas personas
incluyéndome a mí en ese momento
el hecho de que uno sea el único que
tenga hablarse
en nuevos entornos puede ser difícil es
un bombardeo
tuve que aprender francés ticas para
comprender que las personas estaban
tratando de decirme
alguna vez por culpa no alguna vez ha
estado en lugares en costa rica donde lo
costó entender que las personas estaba
tratando de decirle
incluso si puedes decidir su idioma
nativo
incluso que si fuesen todos hemos
sentido así
debido a eso
amplió sus diferencias mi conocimiento
básico en español se volvió
completamente inútil
sí no
y hacer amigos en una nueva escuela era
casi imposible incluso más difícil que
ya lo es para muchos adolescentes
todas esas cosas me separaron a los
demás y me hicieron sentir paranoico y
asustado de que cada día me estaría
ahora todos ustedes si abre sus ojos y
piensa en un momento tan séptimo fue al
lugar
eran en un trabajo o en un país
desconocido todos hemos sentido así
esos tres como lo hacen todos verán
afectado
como en todos los maneras
lo más afectado era mi español
no podía hablar con las personas en
inglés y en español perdón
ya qué
yo sé hablar español
como él muchos como lo muchas personas
hacen en nuevos entornos yo ha creado mi
propio nicho
y eso me dio consuelo ha creado una
estructura de mi vida
las personas hablan español entre ellos
y a mí en inglés
la pregunta más común que me hacen es
usted sabe hablar inglés y cada vez me
hace monótono
hay cosas que las personas no saben de
mí
no soy un estereotipo yo no voy a decir
otra vez
yo sé cómo hablar español pero hay un
gran muro mental que me bloquea el paso
y eso es triste
y es eso cambió completamente mi
estructura estructura de hablar como con
las personas 6 diferente a todos los
demás en cualquier forma causa
discriminación
la gente asuma que el espanyol lo que la
división de la discriminación es dirigir
por cosas
por un grupo general y eso no es cierto
todas las personas pueden ser
discriminados en mi caso era términos
como blondie o gringo
dicen y cada vez más al principio me
descarte en sus comentarios pero hace
muchas veces me sentí peor y peor
no sabe cómo reaccionar que nuevamente
es demasiado triste yo sentí que yo
estaba detrás de una máscara
y amigos y sin saber cómo hablar español
ustedes en un momento
olvidamos quiénes son
fue por culpa sociedad o fue una culpa a
sus amigos no sé estoy seguro de que
mucho ustedes han sentido así
esos cambios realmente ha afectado a mí
como persona
venir cuando llueve vive en inglaterra
el pensamiento era que el español que
las personas extranjeros adaptan bien a
nuestro estilo de vida incluso nuestra
lengua
y eso
no es tan bueno para todo el mundo
porque
porque causa una división entre las
personas
y yo era yo pensaba así antes que
mudarme a costa rica y open yo pensaba
que las personas adaptan a cualquier
cosa que yo hago
y eso no es cierto el mundo es un lugar
diverso con personas de cualquier país
costa rica e inglaterra no sé cualquier
país
y venir a un lugar como reino unido a
costa rica es un gran cambio
como cualquier adolescente sabe que es
difícil
hacer nuevos amigos adaptarán nuevos
entornos
la sociedad en general puede hacer aún
más difícil
y todos los hispanos hispanohablantes
sainz
que somos diferentes y todos vamos ser
diferentes todos los demás en cualquier
país en cualquier parte del mundo
como entonces esté en esas diferencias
me ha cambiado no sólo como persona
verdad
bueno pero un
todo es en esa
todos en esa sala puede lograr algo
grande algo más y algo más que ellos
solo usted necesita es trabajo duro y
una actitud positivo
usted no tiene que ser colocado en un
lugar que usted que determine que usted
fue en o no puede hacer
todos somos diferentes sin embargo todos
somos tan similares todos somos seres
humanos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]